Es un dicho común
que los elefantes nunca olvidan,
pero estos maravillosos animales
son más que unos gigantes
discos duros caminando.
Mientras más aprendemos de los elefantes,
más parece que su impresionante memoria
es sólo un aspecto
de su increíble inteligencia
que los hace una de las más sociales,
creativas y amables criaturas
de la Tierra.
A diferencia de muchos proverbios,
el de memoria de elefante
es científicamente correcto.
Los elefantes conocen
cada miembro de su manada,
son capaces de reconocer
hasta 30 compañeros
por la vista o el olor.
Esto es de gran ayuda mientras migran
o se encuentran con elefantes hostiles.
Ellos también recuerdan y distinguen
señales particulares que indican peligro
y pueden recordar lugares importantes
mucho después de su última visita.
Pero los recuerdos sin relación
con supervivencia son los más fascinantes.
Los elefantes no sólo recuerdan
a sus compañeros de camada,
sino a otras criaturas que
les han causado una gran impresión.
En una ocasión, dos elefantes de circo
que habían actuado juntos brevemente
se regocijaron 23 años después
cuando sus caminos se cruzaron.
Este reconocimiento no se limita
sólo a los de su especie.
Los elefantes también han reconocido
a humanos con los que intimaron
después de décadas de estar separados.
Todo esto indica
que la memoria de los elefantes
va más allá
que la respuesta a un estímulo.
Mirando dentro de sus cabezas,
podemos explicarnos el por qué.
Los elefantes tienen el cerebro más grande
que cualquier mamífero terrestre,
así como un impresionante
cociente de encefalización (CE).
Esto es el tamaño del cerebro esperado
en relación al tamaño corporal
y el CE de los elefantes es casi tan alto
como el de los chimpancés.
Y a pesar de la lejana relación,
la evolución convergente
la ha hecho notablemente similar
al cerebro humano,
el cual tiene muchas neuronas y sinapsis
y un hipocampo y corteza cerebral
muy desarrollados.
El hipocampo está fuertemente asociado
con las emociones que ayudan el recuerdo
codificando experiencias importantes
en recuerdos a largo plazo.
La capacidad de distinguir esta relevancia
hace que la memoria de los elefantes
sea una habilidad compleja y adaptable
más allá de la memoria por repetición.
Es lo que permite a los elefantes
que sobrevivieron una sequía
en su juventud,
reconozcan las señales de advertencia
en la edad adulta,
por lo que los clanes
con matriarcas mayores
tienen mayores tasas de supervivencia.
Desafortunadamente,
esto también hace que los elefantes
sean uno de los pocos animales no humanos
en sufrir trastorno posttraumático.
Por otro lado, la corteza cerebral
permite solucionar problemas,
cosa que los elefantes realizan
de maneras muy creativas.
También abordan los problemas
de forma cooperativa,
a veces incluso
burlando a los investigadores
y manipulando a sus compañeros.
Y han captado aritmética básica,
registrando las cantidades de fruta
en dos canastos
luego de múltiples cambios.
La rara combinación de memoria
y resolución de problemas,
puede explicar
algunos de los comportamientos
más ingeniosos de los elefantes,
pero no explica algunas de las cosas
que recién estamos comenzando
a aprender de sus vidas mentales.
Los elefantes se comunican usando todo,
desde señas corporales
y vocalizaciones,
hasta un retumbo infrarrojo
que puede ser oído
a kilómetros de distancia.
Y su comprensión de la sintaxis
sugiere que tienen
su propio lenguaje y gramática.
Este sentido de lenguaje puede incluso ir
más allá de la simple comunicación.
Los elefantes crean arte,
escogiendo y combinando cuidadosamente
diferentes colores y elementos.
Pueden reconocer 12 tonos de música
y recrear las melodías.
Y sí, hay una banda de elefantes.
Pero quizás lo más sorprendente
es una capacidad,
incluso más importante
que la inteligencia,
su sentido de empatía,
altruismo y justicia.
Los elefantes
son los únicos animales no humanos,
que lamentan la muerte,
realizan rituales de entierro
y vuelven a visitar sus tumbas.
También se preocupan por otras especies.
Un elefante de trabajo
se negó a poner un tronco en un agujero
donde había un perro dormido.
Cuando los elefantes
encuentran seres humanos heridos,
a veces hacen guardia
y los consuelan con su trompa.
Por otro lado,
los ataques de elefantes a los pueblos
han ocurrido usualmente
justo después de la caza furtiva
lo que sugiere una venganza deliberada.
Cuando tomamos en cuenta
toda la evidencia,
junto con el hecho que los elefantes
son una de las pocas especies
que se pueden reconocer
a sí mismos en el espejo,
es difícil no llegar a la conclusión
que son seres conscientes,
inteligentes y emocionales.
Desafortunadamente,
el trato de los humanos a los elefantes
no refleja esto,
ya que siguen sufriendo
por la destrucción de su hábitat en Asia,
la caza furtiva por el marfil en África
y el maltrato en cautividad
en el mundo entero.
Ahora que sabemos de los elefantes
y que continúan enseñándonos
acerca de la inteligencia animal,
es más que nunca muy importante
asegurar lo que el poeta inglés,
John Donne describió como
"gran obra maestra de la naturaleza"
no desaparece del lienzo del mundo.